[Music]
hi folks welcome back to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream Q&A section where we
provide A's to the cues that you present
us that's right are you ready I'm ready
all right so you are gonna read the
questions and we are gonna cogitate and
pontificate and whatever else comes to
mind that's right all right so we're
gonna start as we have before with a
couple of the ones that we missed from
last time two that we plan to come back
to we did not have time to look at so
we're gonna save them for the next time
so we have one from Meyers one from Ryan
Swift you guys know who you are we will
come back to yours next time sorry about
that there's also a question our
opinions with regard to in this together
america.org organization excuse me we've
just we've looked at it just a little
bit not too much
do you want to show that you could show
that yes I won't be able to read any
more questions until it's unshown but so
this is this is the organization we were
being asked about and you know I just
looked at this a tiny tiny tiny bit and
you know I was I was I noted this
declaration of interdependence which is
part of why I went looking for what you
had written back in 2011 it is you know
it's not the same but it looks it looks
good and frankly we're seeing a lot of
these sorts of sorts of coming together
comings together yeah I'm not sure
across a number of domains at the moment
and I you know I don't know a ton about
this particular one it does seem to be
it appears to be what it appears to be
and I'm not sure there needs to be a
single movement like this I think the
fact that they are popping up and
flourishing all over the place is a good
sign that a lot of people are noticing
that the current moment has proven
divisive rather than inclusive and it
denies things like our interdependence
and it moves away from unity so I do not
think that this particular website is
proposing a political solution right
which means that they actually have no
reason not to join forces if they find
us
mission aligned which probably we are so
anyway I don't want to vouch for them I
don't know who they are and upon reading
I hope to be impressed and delighted and
if so once you reach out to us in the
unity 2020 cause because maybe this
would be the quick way to get where all
of us are trying to get us good okay the
the last two questions from livestream
28 the first is a comment Brett the
parking meter has been expired for too
long you need to move your car to me
like you need to move your workbench
that parking meter actually is more
interesting than you realize and for
lack of coins I don't know it certainly
I could have dug up some have coins we
have coins but anyway yes one could fire
it up
with coins and then I have the light go
off of its own accord and at the point
the meter expire but also be making that
classic old parking meter sound as it
ticked down right yet which would be in
the live stream probably not optimal
probably not optimal probably not but
your point about my car is well taken
recently I'm mostly including this for
the final two hash tag recently saw a
Facebook meme that people who wear
glasses are smarter because they trade
graphics for processing power thoughts
also hash tag just lane Maxwell didn't
kill herself will not have killed
herself that's right that's right but
you know I definitely will not have I
would so I saw Eric tweet about this and
I was very much glasses no oh just like
Maxwell yes prepare yourself that what
you expect to happen it's not going to
happen
yeah something else will happen yeah it
would be too obvious if it was it was
that again yep so anyway the question
about glasses yeah there well first of
all there is a a set of trade-offs
involved in frankly reading and what it
does to your eyes as you will soon
discover
your teeth your teeth are suffering from
modernity your eyes are also suffering
from modernity and in fact all of you is
suffering from modernity even as they
are all profiting from modernity as well
you know who's benefiting from modernity
yeah the early modern animal it's a but
anyway yeah there is a certain trade-off
how did you specify it it was trade
graphics for processing power I thought
that's not gonna that's that's not gonna
be yet I think I think that often people
who wear glasses do wear glasses because
they did read a lot as children and
therefore they may have more information
in their heads that's from books that's
about as far as you can sort of I like
it I think that fits the trade-off that
you you optimized for taking in the
information in a very direct fashion at
some cost to your ability to see what
the hell is going on in the world at a
direct level it seems to me it is the
trade-off being specified I don't mean
that I'm not being snide I'm just kind
of what it is I don't know I'm not sure
how you oh you get there well because I
mean is is allowing allowing people who
have there are many other reasons to to
end up with glasses but allowing people
who have had their focus be to close at
a critical developmental period to also
see far away means that it would it
would be a it would appear to be trying
to do an end run around the this or that
trade-off it is reducing the cost side
of the trade-off by restoring vision
with an obvious clewd now the
interesting thing as you walk down the
street and you see people with glasses
and you don't think twice about the fact
that they're wearing glasses the oddity
of people wearing these pieces of
perfectly transparent glass and plastic
shaped in a laboratory to correct for
the distortions of their own eye is
really funny
I mean imagine that instead of being in
a frame which we've gotten so used to
somehow they were hovering this far away
from your face in order that we're
you look the photons were corrected
before they hit your retina so well I
got to say I mean witness cell you
alluded to a podcast you're going to
drop soon about orthodontia which sounds
like it could not be less interesting
but it really it really would have a
hard time being more interesting
actually I would love I don't know who
the relevant person over in aisle and
would be to the guy that you talked to
about dentistry an orthodox
but i would love to have that
conversation and if and if we don't if
there is no such person i would love to
have that conversation with you because
i know that you know just again
anecdotally i started to lose my ability
to see clearly far away when I was 13 or
so and it quickly went completely off
the rails you know I was at like 2,800
went by the time I was 15 but I never
work glasses I work contacts and having
the experience twice a day of like I'm
gonna put in my eyes like I'm actually
gonna put in my eyes now and now I can
see and I take them off like I can't
like I know you're a person but I can't
actually tell who you are and you know
I'm wearing glasses on the livestream
because I started and now it just seems
like the thing to do but you know not
wearing glasses most of the time of my
sort of real life wearing contacts
instead it strikes me as not at all
weird to walk around and see people with
us because it is absolutely a hundred
percent a necessity to move around a
visual world you are of course solving
an internet mystery of how I ended up
with you and the answer is your vision
is not what it might be
that's yours the thing look Internet her
glasses are excellent so yeah it may be
that without them she can't see but she
wears those things you can see I'm
correcting job the X I'm corrected to
better than 20/20 with these matters for
2015 I don't see all of your flaws sorry
and here we are that was not as
comforting isn't done here we are - and
here we are yeah all right okay first
question from today's livestream Wow
this comes in with an amazing donation
to us thank you then it's just a comment
thank you both for being voices of
reason in the middle of a sea of
misinformation this is one of the most
important podcasts on the intern
from that gee thanks Mattie really
appreciate it and another one keep up
the good work so you know we're not
reading a lot of the wonderful comments
that come in but when they come in at
such a such a high dollar amount we do
regarding unity to sway those who are
worried about the greater evil instead
of using a coin flip let's declare the
center-right person would be President
first this would ensure that if the vote
splitting that may occur most of it will
be taken from the right you know I like
this I toyed with an idea like that but
I think the problem is this really needs
to be everybody's plan this isn't a
party it's not you know it is a
patriotic solution to a serious problem
and in order for it to be patriotic and
for it to be all of us it kind of has to
be balanced but I agree
the problem is there are those on the
right who don't want the election
spoiled in the other direction and you
know I can't even say to me we are so
far gone with a system that is so broken
that in the middle of kovat 19 it has
delivered us these two utterly feeble
candidates that we have to we have to go
at this in whatever way allows our
collective interests to override the
interests of the duopoly which have been
so thoroughly the focus of policy for
for at least three decades so in any
case I like the idea that there are
structural biases you could build in to
defeat the lesser evil paradox even
further but I think the point is we
defeat the lesser evil paradox in two
different ways one the structural
balance which we now know from the data
of our volunteers who split evenly
between former Trump former Biden
supporters and 25% of our volunteers are
people who weren't planning to vote in
the first place they're going from not
voting to so interested in this process
that they're willing to volunteer their
time that's an amazing solution to a
problem that we didn't even know we were
gonna solve right so it's let's just say
it's working so well at the structural
level that I don't think we need that
third tier of solution because we have
two tiers that are sufficient
themselves but anyway I like to style up
your thinking it does show a high
quality game-theoretic mind please
discuss the difference between the
narratives enforced by the Daughters of
the Confederacy that created our boomer
and Gen X k12 history education and the
natural desire of our contemporary lives
to push back yeah I mean I like this
look the problem is really simple
history means two different things
okay history means what happened what
actually happened it also means what's
our myth our origin story and the
problem is that we mix these two things
in the classroom and so you get lessons
about how you know Christopher Columbus
discovered America and no he didn't and
no he didn't there was no such person
and America was already inhabited by
fifty to a hundred million people you
can't discover something like that as I
said prior in the prior livestream he
discovered America in the same way that
I have invented the light bulb by screw
and went into the socket it's just not
right so basic point we have to separate
these two things we actually need to
study history which means what actually
happened the good the bad and the ugly
and we need to stop mythologizing inside
of our history discussions right that
has to happen now that doesn't it's not
going to be a comfortable process
because history is not a comfortable
process and to know what actually
happened is going to be a rough ride you
should buckle up but I would suggest
look we're already getting here Guns
Germs and Steel the right approach right
a scientific approach to history
Peter Turchin and cloud dynamics same
thing what are these big patterns about
they're not in general about individual
people and their individual mindsets
they're about bigger processes so we're
now learning how to do this well well
let's keep going the role of central
banking and u.s. monetary policy has
been largely absent from your analysis
of the present situation libertarians
have much to offer here will you bring
them into the conversation yeah
absolutely absolutely no this is central
to the conversation yeah I will say it
hasn't been part of the public
conversation it's
that it hasn't been part of the
discussion it's been implied in the
political solution making discussion
because the point is if you took
Patriots and you put them in a position
to govern based on what's actually going
on and their ability to hash it out
between them you don't think they would
get to this topic I think they'd get
there very very quickly so you know in
some sense we are trying not to advance
policy proposals or positions because
that's counterproductive what we're
saying is look smart courageous Patriots
that's sufficient to get to all of these
big things that we haven't been able to
address in the corrupt system yeah I
mean I would say that you know some some
of the issues that I find most pressing
are things that don't show up at all
that we really haven't we haven't talked
about and I think don't show up in part
because it's not about policy it's it's
not about deciding in advance what
interest groups you're going to speak to
and which ones you are going to
automatically get rid of by virtue of
your position on something so you know
things like things like protecting the
environment and habitat loss and such
aren't aren't anywhere on the docket
because that's not the kind of movement
it is yeah they don't need to be because
you know what good people who don't have
a conflict of interest are going to
protect the environment all right it
doesn't necessarily mean that they're
going to do what any group is advocating
because these groups have conflicts of
interest but protect the environment
that's something we should all be able
to agree on hello do you have an
evolutionary account for spirituality
and mysticism as opposed to specific
sets of religious beliefs Thank You
Brett Heather and Zach for the podcast
yeah that's a great question
yeah that's a great question I would say
the explanation is the same which is
that there is an advantage to both a set
of understood prescriptions that are
delivered in a religious format and
there's also an advantage to a kind of
openness to things that do not
necessarily derive directly from the
analytical you know from introspection
and so I mean it also it seems like sort
of a step a step that has often happened
within lineages where you start out with
something that is explicitly
polytheistic
and then move into monotheism and then
move into something that is you know
does not does not proclaim a single
human like God but it's something a bit
more ethereal less anthropomorphic and
you know all of those are related to one
another but they do tend to go in that
order you know a lot of the polytheistic
belief systems that preceded or the
judeo-christian tradition are imagined
to be sort of you know spiritual
mystical but they were very formalized
polytheistic things you know some of
what people are calling spiritual and
mystical now is just a scattershot I
take what I like I like to imagine that
I'm a mystical person and don't actually
probably aren't actually descriptive of
the Honorable part so if mysticism and
spirituality yeah I agree I do think
it's necessary that we open you know it
used to be that spirituality was sort of
captured by religion because everybody
had a religion yeah in an era where
people are increasingly either not
formally aligned with a religion or
their religion is a grab-bag the
necessity to separate out spirituality
which is basically in some sense license
to suspend the analytical in order to
figure out kind of maybe it's a should
part of the dynamic you know in the is
odd dynamic the art separated from a
rigorous obligation to is is important
to the extent that you cannot derive the
art directly from the is which many of
us believe you can't certain people like
sam harris might argue otherwise
but but that but some license seems to
be necessary yeah next question
easy which is say Kanye West yang as the
unity ticket for 2020 or 2024 question
mark I sure don't think so which is not
to say that West is not motivated by
similar things that motivate us in fact
I'm sure he is I think he is a patriot
he is courageous and he's concerned
and so he announced his run for the
presidency now my guess would be that
he's going to quickly discover why his
run for the presidency is very unlikely
to work and why it could well play into
the scenario that we have in front of us
badly and so I do hope he will make
contact with us because to the extent
that he is trying to solve a problem for
the nation which I believe he is trying
to solve the best way to do that is to
come talk to people who've been thinking
about this structurally and figure out
if we can't align you know that would be
ideal
so anyway Kanye if you're out there we
are absolutely open to talking and
respect further to my question last week
regarding UK Labour Party trumped-up
anti-semitism claims party leader now
backs quote unconscious bias training
your thoughts do I renounce my party
membership or is it or is that just
letting the nonsense win that's a good
question um you know I I the Labour
Party you know the Labour Party and the
Democrats are very similar straits it's
all the same and so really the question
is a what position are you in you know
it may be that you can't you know that's
staying within is the key to getting
somewhere and that you can endure the
what might come back at you as you push
back from within yeah I know I know so
much less about the political system in
England I don't know you know in in the
u.s. to declare yourself independent
rather than a Democrat means that you
lose the right to vote in primaries you
know right I don't know what that would
mean in in the UK you know right now
it's saying your party is it is it
something that you can then say in
conversation to people to make the point
and what is the value of that you know
what are the perks that accrue to being
a party member I don't know yep don't
know I and I confess I don't know enough
about the British system but yeah
definitely the thing that you don't want
to do is empower your enemies by
stepping away from the thing if you have
some influence in it but maybe you have
no influence that's possible too likely
even what do you support a grassroots
canvassing
Unity 2020 at this point a grassroots
canvassing like door-to-door grassroots
canvassing by unity 2020 Oh people are
asking we are we are seeing and
presumably the website is seeing as well
the people who are monitoring that a lot
of people are saying what do I do
like what so there's no ability to
donate dollars at this point so what
what can I do and we've been hearing
some interesting stories about people
talking to their relatives and their
friends people who they wouldn't have
thought would be swayed from either
Trump or Biden yeah we've heard stories
on both sides and they seem to be making
headway because it actually it actually
is a doesn't mean you have to hold your
nose right this plan does not involve
you having to pretend that you're doing
an honorable thing when you're really
not so this I think emerges from okay
this sounds good
what now what can I do okay so here's a
note say first of all get modern okay
you live in the Internet era and a
grassroots having people show up at your
door if it's not totally not one it is
also very powerful yeah although its
covert 19 that's John so yeah nice so
there is a lot you can do online
including reach out to two or maybe
three people who you think have ears to
hear and what you really want to do is
understand what the objections are and
why they don't apply we have designed
around the objections and so you want to
figure out you know people have a
tendency to respond to the thing that's
similar to the thing you're actually
doing
they basically push the thing
cognitively over to something they're
familiar with oh it's a third party
right no it's not there's no there's no
party this is not a third party run and
it doesn't elect the greater evil
because of two design elements it's got
one element that causes it to draw
equally from both sides and it's got
another element that were it to be some
danger in
danger of spoiling the election the plug
gets pulled so you can relax the great
thing about that is you can say well who
are the candidates well no this isn't
about the candidates we've told you what
characteristics they will have to have
right that list is sufficient to get
good people to do the right thing in
office you don't need to know them yet
we don't know them yet it would be
foolish to try to drag people in now
because the effort is still small and
because the effort is still small it's a
hazard to them and it's a basically the
best thing that can happen is the
groundswell can come and then we can
declare who the candidates are and if
you don't like them you're not
committing to support it you're
committing to support something should
we deliver you good candidates and
should the effort be plausible at the
point the election is looming and so
you're not giving anything up you're not
going to do harm in the electoral
context and you are basically just
saying if you deliver on what it is that
you say you are attempting to do then I
would support it right and would you of
course you would write every reasonable
person would you want adults at the helm
you just simply do all of us do this is
too dangerous to have whatever else this
thing you know corrupt children running
things what could possibly go wrong
yeah corrupt children in the bodies of
adults mm-hmm Google allows us to submit
questions to be answered by leaders but
won't allow us to submit them
anonymously therefore people avoid
asking questions that may be sensitive
for fear of retaliation what can I do
I'm not sure
what the context is here is the context
this QA is the context that because this
is going through YouTube that YouTube
does not allow the asking of questions
anonymous I have the sense that must be
it seems like it might be but you know
you can set up a YouTube channel that's
anonymous you know it doesn't doesn't
mean anything and then I'm not the
reason I'm not sure that that's what the
question is is because the word is
leaders and I'm not you know we're not
we might be leaders but that's not our
primary role right here so I'm not sure
what the context is enough to know more
than that
I don't think fear of read retaliation
should be a problem here yeah but it
certainly is in many places of work and
other domains right now and this is a
reason for I mean this is exactly why
there is a strong history of being able
to submit concerns anonymously and of
course now that's being gamed
by some workplaces where people are
submitting concerns against their work
against their colleagues such that
they're not traceable and they're false
so you know there's there's pros and
cons on both sides of that 2020 and 2024
are both too soon please wait till 2040
and push forward as X of ticket well
it's an interesting idea I'm I'm
concerned that 2024 may not even be on
this timeline if we are not able to
divert our course so that 2040 Zach was
born in 2004 SFM Zev who's Eric's second
foreign must have been born in 2005 so
they would be just just old enough at
that point yeah alright tell you I'll
I'll back that ticket when you advance
it then if you're back you're gonna be
2020 now yeah
okay this whole movement of the left is
over an attempt to gain control of
central government which consumes 5
trillion dollars of a 21 trillion dollar
economy maybe
yeah I mean it isn't over an attempt to
gain power yeah clearly please have an
episode of you a progressive patriot and
a Ted Cruz type constitutionalist
patriot and have the illustration of
your new system system you said the
Constitution is showing its age have you
to revise it etc that's a great idea
yep isn't really good night here's the
thing I can't promise it's gonna happen
but I'm working on yeah also I mean you
should we should probably have announced
this at the end of last era but the end
of this area should talk about what's
happening tomorrow as well is that a
live stream it's not live okay but
you're gonna release it soonish sooner
very soon it's just a matter of fact
assuming it's technically difficult so I
have to pull it off first
okay and I don't want to promise it but
it definitely keep talking about it but
not say what it is oh absolutely it's
got great I think so yeah
okay some say that some say that
defunding the police means that people
want to allocate some of the police
budget to other programs and improve the
community others say it will cause
issues of the crime what are your
thoughts um we've talked about this a
bit yeah it's a catastrophe and here's
why
the cops and the necessity to have so
many cops and to have them so well-armed
all of that is a downstream consequence
of really crappy policy designed to keep
people in line after you've frozen them
out of the well being that they're
entitled to so if you then reduce the
level of policing and you reallocate
you're not solving that upstream problem
and so you're going to create a problem
of not enough police so and after the
symptom right grafter the symptom and
some people do say that's what they mean
when they say defund the police and some
people do mean that but not all that
mean that and some of them are quite
obvious in what they're saying when they
say I mean you showed a New York Times
op-ed a week or two ago saying yeah
actually we do mean abolish the police
we mean about no I mean the fact that
there's this one phrase that actually
means two very different things
is part of the problem I mean it's it's
like calling the whole movement
anti-racist when it's frankly patently
not and saying oh we only mean this one
thing well no actually some of you mean
abolish the police entirely and that's a
non-starter therefore you got to at
least
stop using that phrase because some
people are using it to mean something
impossible it would be the equivalent
it's the equivalent of treating a fever
when the fever is actually your body's
way of dealing with a pathogen so you've
got a pathogen you say oh oh my god
you've got a pathogen you've got a fever
the fever is bad therefore get rid of
the fever well now you've got a worse
problem with your pathogen right or
treating pneumonia by denying the
patient fluids all right you're drowning
your lungs are filling with fluid let's
let's dehydrate you well dry you right
up we'll dry you right up yeah it's just
nonsense this is not going to work so
it's not that people like us don't want
to see fewer police we do but we want to
see fewer police by virtue of the fact
that they're no longer necessary by
virtue of the fact that you solve the
upstream problem first it's the obvious
way to go so that's it that's excellent
simple as that's good like you know this
is this this fever point is one that
began to be being made in the 90s with
as Darwinian medicine began to gain
ground and then it kind of stalled out
but you know the recognition that often
a fever is the body's way know the
body's response to the pathogen to raise
the temperature in which the pathogen
exists outside of its optimal zone such
that the pathogen fails but not so high
that the body fails that's not what all
fevers are but that turns out to be what
many fevers are but this the second one
this well one symptom of pneumonia is
that you appear to be drowning let's dry
them up I think actually interjecting
about these examples whenever people say
defund the police it's it is it is the
right analogy knee-jerk medicine yeah
yeah this is New York social change find
the police knee-jerk social change
you've got a whole epidemic of knee-jerk
medicine first your teeth are misaligned
let's drag them to the right place Oh
what could go wrong yes right person's
depressed ah let's give them something
to interfere with the molecules that
facilitate depression do they have
anything to be depressed about that's a
difficult question that's too
complicated let alone an easier request
yeah let's go after the molecules yep
doot-doot where are we can't yes this is
it can you speak to the concern I and
some others have that your unity 2020
strategy even for the next election
cycle might be vulnerable to both
entrenched parties injecting their
candidates as your nominees we see them
coming and we see them coming
we are hostile to them in all that they
do and we will be hostile to the major
parties until they give up evil that's
the thing so now I'm not too worried
about it because let's put it this way
you would be delighted to see the
quality of Patriots who are showing up
in droves on our doorstep looking to
help and you might fool the occasional
Patriot but you're not going to fool us
all I mean we want people who are above
politics period yep I guess we're at
about a half an hour but I want to get
through a few more here before we switch
switch over this made my position clear
to a woke friend children as a group are
sexually abused by adults as a group
therefore all adults Harbor internalized
pedophilia any denial of this assertion
is pedophile fragility that's pretty
darn good that's really good news that's
a really good a'no say it again because
although maybe this should be clipped
but this this is this is snowden bleep
who brings us to us snowden bleeps
strategy is saying this to a friend who
is woke children as a group are sexually
abused by adults as a group
therefore all adults must harbor
internalized pedophilia in any denial of
this assertion is pedophile fragility so
good yeah that's really that's awesome
keep doing that yeah
so someone says they made a flatland
animated movie and the women are squares
okay they also made a sequel called
sphere land please make a documentary on
this new Maoist revolution I need
something to convince my dad wait the
women are squares like they're nerds or
I do so I did not know that there was a
flat land animated movie I do
remember from just rethinking about
flatland a little bit today that the
more sides you have in 2d land the more
elevated you are and you know it's it's
classist as well I think he makes like
tradesmen triangles and the anonymously
at the time and animus author for the
first printing was a square but every
tie there every time you a generation
will change I think you add a side so
the child of a squares of Pentagon if
he's male the childhood Pentagon is a
hexagon and I have to go on an octagon a
nonagon etc so I do wonder if women are
just stabilized as squares in which case
they haven't quite solved it no that's
not not a whole solution yeah that's
interesting point though thanks that
report enough to it curious as to your
thoughts on the warnings that Yuri
basmanov gave us in 1984 after he
defected he is an ex-kgb agent and it
basically mirrors your experiences and
everything you've been saying regarding
evergreen yeah I would
I've seen some of his interviews I think
there's like one longish one maybe an
hour and a half or so but they're a
couple and he just peaced saw it he saw
it in the USSR and he came here and he
said wow you guys have the the
glimmerings of the same kind of thing
and I'm gonna predict these these things
and he just got a lot of them right so
this is Yuri bez enough I think yeah so
the thing to understand is that this is
the canonical failure and exactly a set
of canonical failures so you have what I
call the French Revolution moment which
means the point at which the rent
seekers have frozen regular people out
of well-being for so long that the
regular people think I know you know
pitchforks and torches right and the
next thing it's guillotines that's the
French flair right but but the point is
if you've got run seeking elites and
they freeze people out long enough what
will happen
those people will revolt and so another
canonical failure is this instinct to
you know solve everything through
redistribution which then runs afoul of
a a group selection problem it's got a
game theory problem at its heart if then
forces you to authoritarianism so the
real point is look let's just get good
at saying if you do that the next thing
that happens is this if that happens the
next thing I happens is this and that's
how you end up with that thing that's so
dramatic and everybody says how could
this have happened but does it look like
last time right well but it does it just
got a new tech yeah it's yeah what it
updates and you know for one thing the
things that you're easy that you're
easily gonna spot those things are
understood to be deal breakers and so it
learns you know fascism isn't gonna go
step again it learn it's learned yeah
right
yeah these these people who are like did
you see he did a he did a Heil Hitler
it's like only a true [ __ ] would make
that part of the movement at this point
like it's not gonna look like that of
course it's not do you think CRISPR ooh
biology question do you think CRISPR may
be needed to stop kovat if it mutates
too fast for traditional vaccines what
are the major concerns you have with
this technology thanks and keep up the
great work
hmmm I don't know if CRISPR can be I'm
not I spent a while since I've thought
about CRISPR I don't know how it can be
used to to address kovat if it's
mutating really fast so it can be used
it doesn't it doesn't need to be used
because we have other techniques to do
the same thing it doesn't mean it's not
the most efficient way to do those
things but the thing to understand about
CRISPR is that I have analogized it too
we have a typewriter for the language of
genes and that typewriter is CRISPR what
we don't have is the rosetta stone we
the humans of a typewriter the genes
themselves have whatever they've got
let's do their thing and we now have a
typewriter that allows us to make any
sequence we like right we know what the
letters are we know what the letters are
and we can assemble them at will but we
don't speak the language of those
letters yet we're learning things about
that language but without the rosetta
stone we don't speak the language
means we can't sit down and say let's
write a gene to do X and we've got so
much hubris you know the the molecular
biologists are so sure that they've that
they've got this mailed in so many
regards that changes are often done
without regard to you know things like
Chesterton's fence unattended
consequences it's it's dangerous so I
would say I've seen efforts in the
neighborhood of vaccines and one of the
efforts which is currently being
suppressed it would seem by our
top-level journals makes the following
point in their manuscript about vaccine
technology which is these pathogens have
high variability in terms of their rate
of change and that a vaccine that is
targeted at something that changes
rapidly is obviously a short duration
phenomenon and one can systematically go
through the the genome and the
structures and you can target things to
change less frequently which seems a
very obvious point but nonetheless there
are oh it also makes another point which
is target things that are as far from
human sequences as possible right to the
extent of the pathogen in part profits
by disappearing against the backdrop of
a human you target the parts of it that
are most different because those parts
then do not confuse the immune system
and attacking itself and creating an
autoimmune disease that's good so there
is a way to play this game and the idea
that we are going to because the vaccine
in question is being developed by people
who through their research have
discovered just how probable it is that
the virus emerged from a laboratory
after having been modified that we are
going to shut down that discussion and
thereby slow the progress on that
vaccine is appalling because frankly
that could very easily lead to a great
many needless deaths
one more question here then we'll skip
to switch to the other live stream super
chat are we in the it's just the flu
phase of public awareness of the
horizontal revolution
I like this framing very much me too
I mean it'll like it but I think it's
apt I like that yeah I like it I like it
a lot yeah yeah and you know you can
tell in some sense this is drawn out
because some of us have seen the
horizontal resolution obviously in
microcosm before and we've been talking
about it we were long dismissed and the
point is if it is true that we were
right that the thing that we saw in
miniature has now emerged at a much
greater scale and we told you it was
going to then what are we saying now
yeah we're saying oh my god that's a
threat to the overall power structure
and the worst thing that can happen is
that it can partner with half of the
duopoly right and that's bouches two
reasons one if it partners with half of
the duopoly what's gonna happen well hey
you're gonna get this massive transfer
of well-being based on nothing like
justice whatsoever that is going to
cause misery and the whole point of it
is to distract from where the
opportunity was actually concentrated or
equally bad or maybe worse is that
that's going to activate people on the
other side to fight back and we're gonna
find ourselves in a another race-based
civil war which doesn't even have the
advantage of having a geographical
description that could possibly tell us
how it might be resolved so this is this
is why the alarm bells are going off is
that the duopoly and not donald trump
the duopoly it's a long-standing
conspiracy against the american public
the way it conducts well-being and
concentrates it with rent-seeking elites
that thing has created the problem and
now it is giving us no viable solution
that does not result in disaster for the
country so yeah I agree it ain't the flu
yeah sorry
might males be selecting for fitter
offspring when imposing additional
burdens on females during mating through
biting or hurting so weak females can't
live or carry offspring to term thanks
love you guys wait what um can you help
me I didn't quite get it the the
proposal is that male aggression against
females during mating is a way of
increasing the fitness of their own
offspring this this probably isn't it
because females are always limiting for
males and as you know assuming we're
talking about a species in which there's
no paternal care and basically in which
males try to mate with as many females
as possible and females are stuck with
whatever they have the monopoly on the
parental care such that there is any the
females are a resource that even if
there's a there's a group of offspring
that get produced that aren't as
high-quality as they might be there's
still offspring and conditions change
and what doesn't work now might work in
the future
so in general killing males killing
females is not going to be a viable
strategy and not one that evolution is
going to see is viable either especially
females who are mating with them which
is I realize included in what you just
said but yeah there's nothing down that
road so you know why does that thing
exist
you're a how much does it exist we don't
know and this is people this image that
calls that comes to mind and you know
non-human just like lions you know cats
end up so dividing the male cats end up
biting female cats on the nape of the
neck yeah this is rough yeah yeah so the
nape is that different no it's the
scruff for sure you stuff them right
anyway which I mean in the case of cats
I think it's straightforward if you take
a adult cat and you scruff them it
causes them to to relax and and not
struggle right but that I mean then this
raises a different question about why
any coercion is necessary right right I
mean that's a that's a different
question though that it's not there's
not harm
being there's no intentional harm being
inflicted there yeah okay please talk
about the h-1b issue and how it related
to Eric's theory of minorities in stem
or the Princeton faculty letter I have
to admit that I haven't fully spent time
with the Princeton faculty letter yet
I've seen it but I don't yeah I think
probably you should direct this at Eric
I don't think I want to wade into it
without being fully well-versed someone
offers their support saying it isn't
very much but they're poor well thank
you
yeah thanks and if you're poor probably
save it yeah I would say but thank you
regarding the spoiler issue guys you
can't turn a cruise ship on a dime and
you can't do anything but spoil an
election in four months you're being
naive I love you well we love you too I
don't know what you're talking about the
thing is designed not to spoil the
election what are you worried about
I mean it's designed this way in two
separate ways we've got a by design that
we now know is working mechanism whereby
it draws equally from both and it's got
a fail-safe it's it's it's safe twice
over so yep if religion is inevitable
doesn't it make sense to use science to
carefully design a new religion such
that it's negative externalities are
minimized rather than let harmful new
religions crop up in the wild you know
I've been in this battle multiple times
people who think carefully about how to
fix the problems of civilization that
put us in so much jeopardy always go
through the question somebody will
always raise the question do we have to
invent a religion or is this doomed to
failure if we don't do that hmm and I
think it's the wrong question first of
all there's a problem with building this
in at the religious level which is the
religious level because it is inherently
metaphorical does not have a mechanism
for telling you when the facts on which
the thing is predicated have changed
sufficiently that the myth is no longer
viable in other words the way religions
change is by those who ascribe to
certain you know you've gotten to
fact-checking
yeah it is
optically resistant to fact-checking so
what you've got is sectarian
disagreement over what the true nature
of the religion is and then the groups
that have it closer to right out compete
the groups that have it less right we
can't afford that we have to have
something that self updates what does
that scientific worldview but you don't
want a narrow empiricist scientific
world you want a broad-minded Systems
Theory mechanism that tells you which of
your you know what is stacked on top of
which beliefs such that you know this
belief may not be very if it's wrong it
may not be very important because
there's nothing stacked on it where is
this belief if it's wrong is a terrible
vulnerability and so you need to have
some understanding of what's predicated
on what and therefore what needs to be
checked at what rate and what level of
accuracy it has to have in order to
retain its nature and what would cause
you to change something in order to
avoid something downstream we know how
to do it it's not that hard to figure
out how to do it and I just think it's
incompatible with any system that claims
absolute truth right
now the scientific method will lead you
in a direction of the truth but it
doesn't claim absolute truth there is
nothing that we know that you know for
one thing you hear people talking about
the simulation hypothesis for the
universe virtually everything we know
about what's in the universe isn't true
if the universe is a simulation right
nothing is true does the earth go around
the Sun no not if it's a simulation all
right so so the point is look we're open
to all those things I don't think you
have need to worry that the universe is
a simulation but everything is on the
table in science all the time and that's
the way it needs to be and unfortunately
that's the Achilles heel of all
religions is that they don't do that yep
I wrote an essay on the importance of
semantics redefinition redefinition and
broadening of terms like racism violence
and self-defense do you agree that
semantic distinctions drive much of the
current confusion and how best can we
deal with it I don't know where I'd put
it in the pecking order but it's
certainly a tool that has been used that
it was recognized by the academics who
the sort of revolution in in academia
that helped get us into this mess
redefining language was a primary mode
of dissemination and of confusion yeah I
think the the flaw is that there is a
mindset that mistakes the truth for
social right there is a truth and then
there is a social layer at which we
engage the truth if you think that
everything is social then the world is
effectively like the Internet and you
can you know on the Internet can a man
become a woman
yeah you can sign up for a new account
and say he's a woman and he's a woman
and it doesn't mean that the person
sitting at the keyboard has changed who
what they are but it means that in an
online world that has no physics that
has no conservation laws that has no
absolute logic you know the underlying
code has an absolute logic but online
you can set up a world that does
anything and so if you are raised in
that world and you don't really
understand that the world outside is of
a different nature that it doesn't
really care what you think right that it
is a set of processes that happen
irrespective of whether or not you
understand them then you will tend to
fight your battles in this social layer
because the point is look you who say
that a man cannot become alone by saying
that he's a woman are standing in the
way of people who want to do exactly
that why would you stand in the way
because it's as simple as us all
agreeing to this so if you want to
liberate people let's all agree to it
and the answer is no because you've just
said something that interfaces with
biology and medicine and the prison
system and the courts and all of these
other things and and sport so you know
there's no escaping the fact that those
realms have a physical reality when they
put you in prison you can't just
identify as somebody who's not in prison
all right prison is that an actual place
we take away your freedom and we do it
on the basis of facts established in a
court that tell us that you violated a
law sufficiently important that it
warrants prison time all right those are
yes there's a social layer the court is
a social layer but the bars of the
prisoner not
so I would say to people who have seen
much happen in the social world and have
not fully engaged the boundary between
the social world and the physical world
there is a confusion and that results in
us fighting linguistic battles as if
they are the same thing as reality end
of soapbox on your fourth of July
question in a podcast tenants of
Christianity were mocked and biblical
texts were superficially interpreted see
dr. Peterson's Genesis series where is
the unity in that approach let me say
first I have no idea what you're
referencing to with regard to tenets of
Christianity being mocked I don't I
don't think either of us I've ever done
that well no there are there are
mythical portions that while we don't
mock we aren't going to pretend to
ascribe to and then biblical text being
superficially interpreted but we're not
biblical scholars and we don't pretend
to be we're evolutionary biologists so I
have not watched dr. Peterson's Genesis
series but I imagine that in that as in
everything I have seen of his he does a
really bang-up job yep I think I now
recall what they're talking about okay I
think we talked about virgin birth
so the mythical aspects of crucial
aspect of Christianity and the answer is
all Smet afore eclis true this is not
something for which there is a good
solution on the one hand we are
biologists the idea of virgin birth
that's an empirical claim and the fact
that that claim is in there I find very
unfortunate because what it means is
that there is a an empirical barrier to
people seeing the wisdom of things like
the golden rule in the story of the Good
Samaritan which we'd be much better off
if there were no barrier to seeing the
wisdom there because those aren't
empirical claims well I mean it's
actually it speaks to it you know what
you call the soapbox in the last
question you know we are we are no more
going to agree that Jesus was actually
the result of a virgin birth from his
mother than we are that men can
literally become women by declaring
themselves so they're they're equally
empirical claims and they're equally
wrong well and interestingly the the
version of this that you have picked
somebody who ascribe
to a biblical literalism enough that
that virgin birth is important to them
is very likely not to like the idea that
somebody simply changes sex by saying so
well that's so that's why I picked those
two these are at opposite ends I'd be
like no you can't go after my cherished
beliefs like well sometimes cherished
beliefs are wrong well not only are they
wrong but the point is it's certainly
wrong to say this cherished belief is
sacred you can't touch that one and this
one is blasphemy you have to touch that
one yeah so at some level I hate to say
it I know I understand how it gets heard
and I get in trouble for this but I I've
gone way out of my way to make the point
that these texts are full of wisdom and
it is intermingled with other stuff some
of the wisdom is out of date some of the
wisdom is abhorrent and some of the
wisdom is beautiful it is time that all
of us come together we live together in
a cosmopolitan civilization I don't
think there's any other honorable thing
we can do we must come together and when
we come together we can't all be asked
to treat everybody as Bible as true they
can't all be true because they
contradict each other so if we're not
gonna do that then what we have to do is
back off the claims that Oh mine mines
literal yours may be metaphorical but my
Bible is literal so consider it how much
do you give up if you just simply
recognize virgin birth is a story and it
comes with a lot of wisdom some of which
is incredibly important and has been
widely discovered by many populations
many populations have a version of the
Golden Rule shouldn't we get to the
point where we recognize each other's
humanity and each other's discovery of
that principle and then figure out how
to instantiate it so that it actually is
globalized in the way that frankly I
believe the Buddhists are ahead of
everybody else in truly globalizing it I
cannot support any campaign that does
not make the media enemy number one not
left not right not the center well unit
you will Unity 2020 fight the media so
this is this is going down the same
route that the both parties and the
duopoly have gone down they start with
policies that they care about issues
that they care about and they start
courting those interests which some will
argue are not special interests but
global interests but they start courting
them and then those become central and
then the the party whatever it is or the
movement in this case changes such that
that is its focus is is what is
happening to the media a problem yeah I
could pick three things that I would
focus on before the media but the B is a
problem but all of us would pick you
know would have a different ordering we
could probably agree many of us on the
top 20 let's call it issues that are
facing our country 20 we could probably
probably agree on a list of 20 but
ranking that list boy that's gonna be
tough I don't think that we're going to
get agreement on a ranked list I'm not
even sure you and I would agree on a
ranked list No we'd come we'd come
really close because I don't think we'd
exactly agree well so the idea that it's
got to be your issue or you're not on
board that's going to be a problem that
is the opposite of unity
yeah I would say the other thing is
they're trying to figure out how to how
to come out the question it's this one
there are bound to be people in all of
the layers including media who are of
the following three descriptions you're
gonna have people who will serve
themselves no matter what the harm is to
others you're gonna have people who will
do the right thing irrespective of the
harm to self and then you're gonna have
a lot of people in the middle who are
going to do what makes sense relative to
the incentives that they find and many
of those people would prefer a system
that worked they would prefer to feel
good about their job and they don't have
the option to do it because of perverse
incentives in that layer and so here's
the question suppose you put aside your
let's go after the media first position
and instead you thought how do we build
something that those people in the media
who actually would be aligned with us if
they could find that if they could find
the opportunity how do
create the opportunity a groundswell
we'll do it right and you will still
have people in the media who are really
just there to serve their own interests
but I don't think they're gonna be the
majority so imagine that every one of
the things that we might prioritize has
those same three layers in it and figure
out how it is that you are going to
liberate those who are trapped in the
system who would prefer something that
actually worked how do you liberate them
to join us so that we can get to a place
where things function again okay we're
coming up in an hour but we've got a lot
of what look like really good questions
we'll get through as many of them as
possible and answer a few more at the
top of the next livestream which will
not incidentally we'll say this again be
Saturday but will be the following
Tuesday a week from today Oh someone
says everything is going to be okay the
Holy Spirit is here for you stay strong
God's children will be victorious I
think that belief is not helpful now
because by putting it into someone
else's hands it means that change is not
likely to happen how right was JK
Rowling when she wrote to call him
Voldemort Harry always use the proper
name for things fear of a name increases
fear of the thing itself I've always
thought it was a very strong element in
yeah in in those books I think the fact
that Arry doesn't use the fancy spells
it doesn't prefer them is a very
powerful message and the fact that he is
alone unafraid to speak the name of
ultimart that both of those things
actually suggests a kind of deep
understanding of how things really go
wrong speak the true name yeah yeah how
can the silent majority in quotes that
is not aligned with BLM anti-police
defund the police agenda protect their
communities from becoming criminal
havens I mean so much depends on the
particular context right well one thing
that as people approach us and they say
well okay it's happening at my
institution what do I do
or it's happening in my city what do I
do at some level you can tell by the
lack of
diversity and how successful people are
at fending off these things the fact
that the same belief system is spreading
across the landscape and then basically
you can be earlier or later but that
sooner or later it's gonna wash over you
and people are gonna start saying the
same thing about you know about white
supremacy being everywhere and white
fragility being the only explanation for
why anybody would not agree that because
that does wash over everything you can
tell that the solution isn't at a lower
level where how do you protect your
community well what's the likelihood why
nobody's successfully protecting their
community or their institution that
you're gonna pull it off there therefore
the solution is to do it at a higher
level in other words how do we address
the thing that is causing people to be
vulnerable to this this ideology washing
over them and causing them to say a lot
of untrue things so I think the thing is
unfortunately there's no solution at
that level join us at the higher level
and let's solve the whole thing once and
for all
okay couple more questions
according to ballotpedia filing
deadlines for independent candidate
ballot access have already passed in
several states did your plan have a way
to get around this yes regarding a
spoiler why not aim to influence the VP
pick for Biden get one of our candidates
installed as VP it would be a
substantial way to put us on the map but
not risking spoiler and trump version
two well first of all again why does
everybody think we're risking spoiling
right it's twice twice safe right that
said if the Democrats want to play ball
or the Republicans want to play ball and
start governing right if they want to
give a strong indication that they are
interested in leadership and they have
given up their influence peddling racket
we're all ears so yes there are things
down that road but boy are we gonna take
some convincing that they've actually
come around because you know what the
signs are quite the opposite that's
right
well I bet [ __ ] crazy and not say catch
it or bird [ __ ] or any of a wide variety
of you know droppings well a lot you
take this I mean I mean I can I can riff
on it too good question I'm gonna leave
it I'm saving something oh this front oh
really
I am okay I am
but yeah if it turns out to be a deep
question they can't get the typically
nice bring us welcome before his name
bats have kind of a PR problem I mean
they just do yes especially now right
and also I don't know the answer to the
question but um it could be the bats fly
and it's it's the roosting in caves
isn't it it's yes David they are problem
that's in part based on their cave 'no
sand dart no they're not their problem
is based in part on the reality that
because guano of all sorts is which
tends to be i think only really what we
call it when it's bats somehow or guess
ariel yeah when it's when it's something
[ __ ] from this guy that pathogens
are concentrated in it and they can't
become aerosolized and that's all very
fine and good if you're a seabird on our
rock it's gonna dissipate in the air
just like being outside you're much less
likely to be contracting kovat but if
you're in a cave all of that is is
concentrated it doesn't really have any
place to leave so if you enter a cave
where there are a bunch of bats roosting
you're actually much more likely to get
exposed to something that might actually
make you act crazy then if you walk into
a cave without such bats or if you're
just walking through some you know cave
landscape without actual caves yep good
like that
what about Kanye is the question could
Kanye West play a role in the Unity 2020
plan think of his vision that's why all
ready went you ready yeah of course he
could play a role and we would we would
welcome him playing a role I don't think
the role is president it just doesn't
make sense yeah um you know he's got
amazing skills but I don't think it's at
all indicated that his skills are of the
kind or that he would even want the job
really yeah okay let's take one more one
more and then we will stop for now with
a few announcements to end thank you for
your work I am a person of color working
at a religious private school I just
signed up for a book club to read white
fragility with colleagues who are mostly
female white upper-class etc any advice
wakil up
buckle up yeah first of all your
description of the demographic
descriptors of the other people who are
in this book club is is telling and is
typical it does tend to be pretty much
middle-class and upper-class white women
who are promoting this particular book
this particular screed that is so filled
with hatred and ridiculous thinking and
that you know why that might be as a
conversation not for right now but but
for another time but you know I would
say at one level you know you play the
idiocy of the book to your advantage in
order to get them to listen to you if if
you were the person of color in the room
and you are listening to us and
therefore at least have some suspicion
that the book is not what it claims and
is divisive rather than unifying if they
start disagreeing with you point out
that they they actually have no leg to
stand on on this room because you are do
you where the person who is suffering
rather than rather than them yeah I just
don't see anything dishonourable in
playing their game on them at the point
that they would insist on winning
regardless of whatever else is true I
might come out slightly differently but
in part we don't know what you mean by
POC because let's say you're Asian and
we also don't know from blamed sorry but
from your name I can't tell if you're
male or female and so that's going to be
probably probably more effective if
you're female although frankly a woman
pushing back against other women is
going to play very differently gonna
have to use different strategies than a
man pushing back against a group of
women but I would say if by POC you mean
that you're black then maybe it's a
marvelous opportunity now it's certainly
not an opportunity without risk
but imagine for example that the
approach you took was I've read the book
I don't believe it and as people in the
room are trying to insist that they are
racist and are trying to come to grips
with it and that it is the kind of
problem that must be addressed and can't
be addressed and all of the other
contradictions that these people espouse
you might just call them out in their
own
interest and they might hear you trying
to liberate them from this set of
circular idiocy 'he's right if they
heard you saying you know what I hear
you asserting that you're definitely
racist because you're white my
experience that's not how it worked I
mean that's just not the nature of it so
now you began with a caveat and
basically unfortunately if your lineage
making you a person of color is East
Asian and they this doesn't show up in
white fragility but it's certainly in
the ideology probably what will come
back at you is well Asians are a tool of
white supremacy as well yeah which is a
line that we ran into it evergreen and
you know it's quite common it's it's
absurd and ridiculous and offensive and
all of these things but you know you're
you're most protected against the idiot
ideology the I guess the targa the skin
here is the darker your skin is well
case it's ridiculous you don't imagine
that if you are black do not imagine
that because you are black you will be
safe I would say it depends on one of
two things or it depends on one primary
thing yeah is if the people pushing the
ideology are really in the room rather
than people who are a victim of this
ideology that is to say they are being
forced into admitting things that aren't
true if the people who are leading it
are there then you're in for special
punishment because mm-hmm claiming that
you don't see it is going to be viewed
as very damning yeah but he or she has
said book club so maybe maybe not yeah
the chances are that you're dealing with
basically people who are engaged in
embracing a zombie ideology but the the
people who are selling it aren't there
in which case you might be able to
liberate them yeah all right I think I
think that's it you want to put up the
end screen while we talk just so we will
not be here on Saturday for logistical
reasons on our end but there will be one
two maybe three podcasts up between now
and next Tuesday when will
we will be back live at 12:30 I would
remind us yet again remind you guys
about the darkish membership at my
patreon at the $5 and off level about
the discord server it's available at
either the link to that available either
of our patreon z' but all the dark wares
clips channel which is now alive and on
which you can find hopefully whatever
your favorite clips that you were hoping
to share from the last few episodes and
they'll be keeping current from now on
and you wanted to say something about
what you're going to be doing tomorrow
or do you want to keep that a surprise
I will just say God's willing and by
gods I mean technical gods willing we
have an awesome podcast headed your way
I am certain of it before it has even
landed on the sensors in our cameras so
anyway keep your eye out for that but I
don't want to promise it because the
technical issues are daunting and Zac is
hundreds of miles away so in any case
like subscribe comment and please join
unity 2020 to find us announce your
presence and find two or three other
people and tell them hey this plan it's
not what you think it is you've heard of
third-party plans this isn't a third
party it's not gonna spoil the election
give it a chance
all right thanks folks seamless outro
you
you